this afternoon we're hearing from the
teens at the center of that violent
smoke shop robbery for the very first
time that's right we first shared video
from inside the store last week showing
the owner of the shop grabbing a knife
and stabbing one of the would-be robbers
today only the 8 news now i-team's
vanessa murphy was in court as the case
against the teens moves forward we do
want to warn you video in this report is
of a sensitive nature
two of the teens admitted to the robbery
here in juvenile court while the third
who was stabbed by the store owner
remains in the hospital do you admit or
deny that you did it yes
also in your agreement you agree to pay
restitution on all counts even those
that have been dismissed is that correct
two teens pleading guilty to this
robbery at a las vegas smoke shop on
august 3rd while this teen still
recovers after the store owner
repeatedly stabbed him when he jumped
over the counter wednesday in court
judge sonny bailey allowing our camera
with the condition of not identifying
the teens or their parents here she
addresses the teen seen here at the door
rather than render aid you and the other
co-defendant took off and left him and
left in a right share the 8 news now
i-team learning all three teens already
have juvenile records the teen at the
door on probation the teens at the
counter on gps monitoring judge bailey
is demanding answers court expects
probation to appear to explain to this
court how two co-defendants on a gps
manage to not
have their units and their alarms off
and not be picked up in violation of
their gps when this offense occurred it
was also revealed the teens met in drug
court instead of going to drug court and
trying to
you know get good control over your
urges he's over there meeting up with
accomplices and planning planning crimes
and committing crimes the attorney for
the teen in the hospital says until
swelling goes down from his injuries
it's unclear what the damage will be the
store owner has not been arrested and he
says he feared for his life metro police
say this is an ongoing investigation and
the case will be forwarded to the clark
county district attorney's office to
make a decision the attorney for the
teen at the door says there is no
indication any of them had weapons no
guns no
knives and nothing
of the sort but unfortunately things
happened the way that they did both
teens who agreed to the plea deal have
not yet been sentenced reporting from
juvenile court vanessa murphy live local
now
and according to juvenile probation the
teen at the door may have tried to
previously rob the same smoke shop he
also may have known the store owner kept
a knife the teens are expected back in
court in two weeks time